russian tanks roll into ukraine the
target the capital kiev ukraine's
president says the response from the
west is not good enough so what are the
options can ukraine defend itself this
is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
muhammad zhum russia's invasion of
ukraine is intensifying with air and
ground assaults russian troops have
taken several towns and cities and also
the chernobyl nuclear disaster site now
they're attacking the capital kiev
[Music]
explosions and gunfire have forced
hundreds of thousands of people to
escape to subway stations and makeshift
bomb shelters russian tanks have arrived
over the border from belarus ukraine's
president velodimir zelinski says russia
is targeting civilian areas he is
calling for stronger sanctions against
moscow adding his country is being
forced to fight alone
when bombs fall on kiev it happens in
europe not just in ukraine when missiles
kill our people it's the death of
europeans i demand greater security for
europe greater protection for ukraine as
part of a democratic world
the u.s australia and japan are among
those countries who have now imposed
more sanctions against russia european
union leaders agreed to target russia's
financial system state-owned companies
and business people but the measure
stopped short of blocking russia from
the swift global payment system the
kremlin promised retaliatory sanctions
russia's foreign minister says moscow
will only hold talks with kiev when
ukraine's army surrenders sergey lavrov
accused ukraine's president of being
insincere
he is simply lying to you when he says
he's ready to discuss ukraine's neutral
status we suggested all sorts of options
and president putin discussed it with
macron and he said it directly the
expansion of nato is unacceptable we
wanted to seek further security options
which would be guaranteeing demands for
ukraine european nations and russia but
our demands on security guarantees have
not been met
[Music]
all right let's introduce our panel in
kiev helena yanchenko she's a member of
the ukrainian parliament
in moscow dmitry bridget a russian
political analyst
and in london andreas krieg he's an
assistant professor at the defense
studies department at king's college
london a warm welcome to you all and
thanks for joining us today on inside
story helena let me start with you today
president zielinski has said that the
response from the west is not good
enough he is urging europe to act more
quickly in imposing sanctions on moscow
he says that the west has been too slow
to respond
what do ukrainians want to see right now
what do they want to see immediately
from the west
well
i should tell you that actually uh
we in ukraine are shocked because of the
situation
because putin was lying to ukraine and
to the whole world
he and his close associates his speaker
his minister of uh
foreign affairs said that they will not
attack ukraine they will not invade
ukraine and for the second day in a row
the whole world sees it was a lie
yesterday
i woke up in cave and i am in kiev at my
home i woke up at 5 00 am because of
explosions in kiev
the situation is horrible they are
attacking both military
uh objects but also civilian objects
uh today uh the russians were attacking
a city called akhtirka
with the hurricane
wally fire system they bombed
kindergarten and some children died
civilian children and some adult died
because of russian weapon so what do we
expect world
two things are
urgent uh and should be uh
should be implemented immediately number
one is
block russia from
swift until
putin
is in swift system he can continue
funding this war against ukraine in
european country
second urgent thing is no fly zone
above ukraine because russians
are using their aviation they're using
their
rockets
and they are a fire walled fire system
to bomb ukrainian cities all over the
country all regions
and
people in ukraine are horrified a lot of
civilians were murdered yesterday
and uh and today because of russian uh
military and uh russian arms so two
things block russia from swift system
immediately so they can't fund
continue fund funding the war
and and the second thing
is
no flying zone above ukraine
andreas you heard helena there say that
a no-fly zone is needed immediately
do you think that's something that could
eventually become a possibility and also
i'm curious about your perspective about
if you believe that ukraine is able to
defend itself right now
yeah great um obviously this is a major
um act of aggression by russia that you
know the western world and the
international community very firmly
stand behind
the ukraine but there is also on the
other hand
there is this idea of feasibility how
much are we willing to support and we
are supporting the ukraine without
getting dragged directly into a military
confrontation with russia and that's i
think where the deterrence of the west
has kind of failed but i do believe that
there needs to be a full spectrum
response to what what russia is doing
because russia is using all domains all
levers of power to advance its interest
in ukraine not just the military one so
i fully agree i mean the swift response
is a very important one and
i hope that you know especially germany
could really rally around
that idea but from a military point of
view a no-fly zone is certainly a very
very important factor here because i
think the air superiority of of russia
at this point is probably the most
important competitive advantage that
russia has uh operational advantage as
well over uh over the ukrainian armed
forces so what the west has delivered so
far which are anti uh aircraft missiles
uh has been already fairly effective you
know a lot of aircrafts rotary aircraft
as well as fixed-wing across have been
shot down so far but it's not enough um
air defense systems need to be uh need
to be uh obviously bolstered the
resilience of the air defense in ukraine
has to be increased the problem with
that is that the systems that could be
delivered to ukraine don't just need to
be shifted into the ukraine but there
needs to be a training uh element to it
as well which at this point in time as
the war has already started is very very
difficult a no-fly zone itself certainly
would address that issue
but would come with immense risk for the
west because it would mean that you
would have to enforce it coercively
against the russian air force where
where things happening at rapid speed uh
with a huge huge risk i think for uh for
nato forces to get dracked into a kind
of article 5
kind of moment or territory where you
know nato nato planes would have to
fight russian planes there's a lot of
leeway and a lot of room for mistakes
particularly as things happen very very
very quickly um and you know nato could
see
big be very quickly in a space where it
would have to fight russia and have to
reply to aggression or reply actively
against
russian aggression against its own
forces that is something that at this
point nato is definitely is a risk that
nato is not willing to take dmitry this
is all moving very fast right now do you
believe that we will get to the point
where nato is forced to step in
i don't think so right now because it
could be a dangerous for nato and for
european countries because right now if
nato will uh will support ukraine
other european countries will be in part
of that war and also some people some
members of nato they don't want to have
this war with russia like turkey and
other countries some other european
countries so it's obvious like right now
that nato only can support um ukrainian
by giving them weapons to defend
themselves from the russian invasion but
it's obvious that it won't help them in
this situation because um right now as i
hear from news from different uh
the news say that um like russian army
is not far from the ukrainian uh from
the ukrainian capital city kiev so it's
obvious that putin wants to he was
trying to um to take control over kiev
and the change change the government
there and to put the governor another
governor another government or president
that will support russian agenda in this
region and
that
on other option that i see putin is
giving for ukraine is not to be part of
european union and nato that was what's
doing putin right now
helena the kremlin is saying that russia
is ready to send a delegation to belarus
for talks with ukrainian officials from
your vantage point is the door to
diplomacy open in any way right now or
has it shut completely
the door of diplomacy is shut but we can
open it
in order to open it putin should stop
uh
stop killing ukrainians
and stop uh invading continue invasions
to ukraine because we have dozens of
russian tanks on the territory that
invaded territory of ukraine yesterday
we have those
not thousands hundreds thousands of
russian uh soldiers and military
units on the territory of of ukraine so
they should stop killing ukrainian
civilians
in order to start a negotiation
however i should
tell that
negotiation
means communication from two sides and
not ultimatum of one side what russia
wants uh
as of as of now they want couple things
from ukraine and these things are really
unacceptable in my opinion they want us
to give them part of our
sovereign territory
including donetsk and lugansk region the
whole region not only the temporary
occupied territories they want us to
uh
to delete our army and
give away all our arms and weapon so
like
total demilitarization of the whole
country
they want uh
they want some other things that
actually uh will make us uh
very vulnerable because we will not be
able to protect ourselves and
already
in
1994 if i'm not mistaken ukraine already
believed russia when we signed bucharest
memorandum and we gave away our nuclear
weapon to russia
and
in return to that
three countries russia great britain and
usa
promise that they will protect our
borders
if that's the way russia protect our
borders
then i'm sorry this you know this
memorandums
uh
are not working and our country is not
protected but we gave away our nuclear
our nuclear power so
negotiations
is you know suicide communication not
ultimatum from russia side only dimitri
what do you say does this just continue
to devolve into a long-term full-blown
conflict or is there any room here now
for diplomacy going forward and also
what is president putin's ultimate goal
here
it's obvious that putin um now
what will happen is the hands of putin
he will like it's your option either to
stop the war either to go to something
to diplomacy so it's obvious now uh uh
it's obvious that putin wants to
try to take control over um kiev you
want to change the government you want
the government that will support him and
we as we know he did the same thing in
belarus when he supported
alexander lukashenko against the uh
protests against the position as obvious
that he do he's doing the same thing in
ukraine but with other uh with the uh
with other power with others
like his political uh power and he's
trying to now to say he's saying inside
russia that he's helping russians in
ukraine that is fighting against the
nazis or whatever so it's obvious now
that um putin's plan is to change the
government there to put a government
that will support his agenda or plans
for europe and he also should like he
don't he is planning to um he see a
grain that ukrainian plan to john
european union and nato is dangerous for
him for him because as we saw the same
thing happened belarus in kazakhstan he
supported a government that will support
him and will support russian agenda
in the world
andreas if this were to become a
long-term occupation would president
putin and russian forces be able to
sustain
you know these long-term intensive
fighting in ukraine
no absolutely not i i do firmly believe
that this is a
a timely planned as a very short term he
calls it a special military operation
limited in scope limited in time it
needs i think it is about decapitation i
i agree with the previous speaker it's
about kind of bringing about regime
change in kiev um but that has to kind
of happen fairly quickly i think if
russia now gets bogged down in a in a
stalemate type of operation because we
we shouldn't uh make the mistake as some
analysts have done over the last couple
of days it came two days to compare the
situation in ukraine with that in syria
uh where you know the where the russians
were firmly successful this is a it's
quite a major war the ukrainians are
very very uh well trained they're well
equipped and most importantly they have
quite a lot of resolve to fight back
what they see as an aggressor there is
no you know this is not a divided
country where there's 50 pro and 50
against russia the country very firmly
stands against russia and in support of
the kiev government so the environment
is very ripe for an insurgency and it's
anyway so
russia cannot have an interest in being
dragged down in a quagmire of a
prolonged conflict and trying to control
particularly uh you know local
communities because i think already we
see local communities taking up arms and
fighting for uh for uh you know their
country and then think this is something
also there are an opportunity there for
western countries and we've seen this
today when the uk defense minister
already made a reference to potential
surrogate operations giving support to
ukrainians even in territories that have
already been seized by the russians i
think there are opportunities to kind of
mobilize local very resolved uh uh you
know mobilized um a a firm resistance
against russian occupation if it ever
came to an occupation but you know there
is also something this this war is very
very unpopular in russia uh and i think
as this drags on and body bags will
mount and you know right putin has a
huge risk i think he's taken a huge risk
here in in potentially losing his own
street at home potentially not being
able to seize objectives very firmly and
a protracted conflict is not something
that he will or want to sustain for in
in previous previous periods russia has
always delegated these sort of wars as
in syria two local surrogates two
mercenaries and this is not something he
can do in ukraine because he's up
against a very very robust uh opposition
the most important thing is though that
the ukrainian forces now retain a level
of resilience where the government
retains a certain degree of resilience
to actually fight back and not
critically failing because that is
something over time time is working for
the ukraine and time is working against
russia so the longer this takes i think
the more difficult it would become for
putin to achieve objectives dmitry
andreas was just saying that he believes
that this conflict is an unpopular one
in russia among the population the fact
that there have been protests scattered
across russia does that worry president
putin at all is there a sense that he is
misjudging the mood of the russian
people and could that be to his
detriment
we have in russia took a tour of people
one part of people or that's all from
the soviet union the soviet union
generation to support uh putin's uh like
plan or putin's war in ukraine the
putin's invading ukraine another part of
the young generation did not support we
saw how people they uh they were
protesting against the war they don't
want they don't want to have a war with
a country that they have relatives uh
with they have families living there so
it's obvious now we have uh now
um and russia two categories of people
and it's obvious that putin was doing
that for
elections in 2024 we have president
elections he wants to get more popular
because now his popularity is getting
low it's not he's not popular as it was
in the past and he had problems with the
position but now he has the full control
of country he's going to do whatever he
wants he can like do a war he can create
a big war or he can end this war so it's
obvious now in russia if uh obviously if
the war will want and only people fresh
on the on the citizens of russia they
can't stop putin and stop this war but
it's obvious that people they scared to
get uh to get on streets it's to speak
freely because there are a problem with
they have
a lot money people arrested and this
obvious that government is they want to
listen to them
helena earlier in the show you said that
from your perspective that what's needed
right now is a no-fly zone and you said
also that russia basically needs to be
shut out of the swift global payment
system
if that fails to happen if those two
things fail to happen and in the event
that western allies
don't step in any further how else is
ukraine going to be able to defend
itself against russia
well i should tell that we already
defend ourselves for
for yesterday and for today it's
basically ukrainian army only and a lot
of civilian men and women are coming to
territorial
point of territorial defense to get some
weapon and to defend their cities and
their communities
but if
west
continue you know being
deeply concerned without no
concrete action
then uh they should know that
not only the blood of murdered civilian
ukrainians will be on their hands but
also some uh potentially
horrible ecological catastrophe
one thing that uh
not many people are talking about is
that
russia yesterday russian troops
captured chernobyl zone it's the biggest
ukrainian nuclear weapon nuclear plant
and also the biggest nuclear plant in
europe which already exposed in
1986
uh
they mess around with chernobyl with a
weapon
with their fire system
and
they
actually might
might use chernobyl as a further a
platform to
invade to a cave so if they uh
if they
uh like disturb the
this nuclear
nuclear plant or do something to psycho
[ __ ] that uh that protects the
exploded part of uh
of the plant
uh the ecological
catastrophe will be not only in ukraine
but it will be a
the hugest ecological catastrophe of the
uh of this century in the world and then
the whole world should react to save
their people from ecological
from europe catastrophe
is why that is why
close uh no-fly
zone is uh is is an immediate uh
is an immediate thing because russians
they keep sending their rockets and they
are
their aviation
to all uh regions of ukraine including
kiev oblast where chernobyl nuclear
plant
and surf sarcophagus
andreas from your perspective just how
dangerous a moment do we find ourselves
in right now and do you believe there is
potential that this conflict could
spread to a nato country going forward
well i mean first and foremost i mean
what i what i disagree with generally in
the discords over the last couple of
months has been that people are talking
about a potential war in ukraine a
potential invasion coming into ukraine
this war has been going on for at least
since 2014 and for the russians it's a
it's a war that's been going on since
the early 90s so um we're already seeing
aggression by russia you know outside of
ukraine into nato territory it's just
we've now seen an escalation of that
sort um of warfare in ukraine with a
combined arms approach but you know this
is an ongoing conflict that for russia
is all kind of connected to other what
they call buffer zones in uh between
nato and and russia and most importantly
the baltic states so we should be under
no illusion that any decision that the
west is making any kind of projection of
power that nato is making any decision
that nato is making at this point in
time will eventually
determine how far russia is going when
it comes to actually threatening nato
territory as they're already doing at
the moment so the resilience and also
the resolve that nato has to show now
has to be it has to be very very firm we
can't have certain countries opting out
and i think germany has been one of the
countries that has been mostly opting
out of a joint european or joint nato uh
decision against how to clamp down on
russia i think britain is taking kind of
a lead here in europe and taking a very
firm position when it comes to
supporting ukraine and also doing more
this is a very dangerous moment but it's
also a defining moment i think for the
next decades to determine the
relationship and also the boundaries
between western sway of insulin nato's
way of influence and russia's way of
influence all right well we have run out
of time so we're going to have to leave
the discussion there thank you so much
to our guests helena yanchenko dimitri
bridget and andreas krieg
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story from me
muhammad jim joomla the whole team here
bye for now
[Music]
you